crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
yeah you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every to see you
already you do though
Orion take the soccer star Joe go above
ground cool goes better than most Jane
Austen self-diagnose go down low this
week last week here we go again for the
crab feast
welcome back to the crab feast y'all saw
the to the crab fees for that ass mix it
up today play good to see a jailer
always good to see you
Jay Larson here feast nation I love you
Jay Larson comedy icon Branson comedy on
all social media and I do say when I say
I love you I do mean it and I want to
say thank everyone who shouted out to me
about Conan last week I didn't I didn't
expect that you guys are really sweet
and it always means more when I hear
from features so I appreciate that I
also want to say this weekend I'm in
Atlanta at the Laughing Skull lounge
recording my CD 2nd album and last I
think you all know I'm retiring from
stand-up so I'm recording Friday and
Saturday night laughing so but there are
shows Thursday and Sunday as well but if
you want to come to recording that'd be
great if you don't he'll and a column
tell them to be there and as always best
bars in America all you guys that are
watching and I appreciate it if you
don't
please watch Wednesday nights 9 o'clock
on Esquire network sickle-cell Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook Ryan Sickler comm 2 shows I
want to tell you about Sunday June 14th
at the Irvine improv your boy Jay Larson
comedy and myself for doing a crap feets
anniversary stand-up show come on out
get your tickets there on Ryan Sickler
calm and the crab feast calm I'm also
headlining the San Francisco punchline
on Wednesday June 24th one that only
come on out San Francisco Bay Area fee
stirs I want to see the love you can get
those tickets also Ryan took on the crab
feast calm your merch all free domestic
shipping all right all orders include
free domestic shipping thank you for the
Amazon love it's tremendous help all
premium episodes now are available on
iTunes Androids non iTunes users all
through Gumroad
they're only a buck 99 you can get those
on the craft fees.com hit that premium
app lengths are there the Facebook fan
page you're looking for some extra crab
feast the end of the week go get a
premium out there there are some of the
best EPS out there because we have two
guests yeah and believe me we don't get
that dollar net inking iTunes page
keep those five star reviews coming
y'all we love you stitcher and
SoundCloud some of you we try to listen
through SoundCloud but
doesn't update properly so we're on them
through all things comedy getting on
those guys Mike Flint over there follow
all things comedy on Twitter and all
social media I also want to say to you
guys you know we're as strong as we are
feature nation you know so if you guys
have any things that you see other
people doing on podcasts do you think
would be fun for us to do that might
make it a better podcast emails let us
know we always listen to you guys we
love you guys and that's some you know
guest yeah think would be great anything
we're always better and we usually do
think just like it sometimes people are
hitting us up like you should have this
guy on our back this week Cameron Hughes
wine someone as you know talking about
someone we can learn from Cameron Hughes
man doing it right I think everybody
we've talked about that some of the best
wine comes from the best vines and it
sometimes those producers that have the
best vines make too much wine and
Cameron Hughes is scooping it up this
week featured bottle lot 4 4 6 2013
Spanish garden ahsha I have no idea if
that's how you pronounce it I don't even
know if you said that right or not
either
yeah well that's that's what I love
about Cameron Hughes is that we don't
need to know anything he's doing all the
work to chronic it's an exhaust you need
to know was lot four four six Cameron
Hughes recently found this it's a
Spanish ganache I made from 40 to 60
year old Bush vine siliceous okay the
older the better as far as what I say
European wines have been difficult the
last few years and the cost of the euro
and subpar vintages is taking it down
but Cameron who saw four four six and
was like too good I'm doing it cherry
raspberry hints of white pepper
dude something about white pepper what
sounds good to me it really does this is
like a great like wine to have on a
Tuesday onand on a Tuesday with dinner
you know it's a nice table wine nice
dinner wine it's 10 bucks dude it's a
$10 wine it's a no-brainer ship to your
house ship it free shipping and I've
said this before you know I'm a sucker
sometimes for these wine deals that
they'll email you and I always go for
the wines that are like been raided I
don't care I look for a cheap price and
one that's rated to of his wines
recently have been bike by Wine
Spectator over 90 points dude and that's
like the guy Wine Spectator so listen
here's the deal free shipping on your
order of wine for this exclusive Spanish
guard
for only ten bucks go to ch wine calm
click on the microphone in the upper
left corner and enter our code crab fee
CH wine comm microphone crab feast
if you drink wine this is a no-brainer
it's free to your home you get it and
you put it in the wine fridge or you
drink it that night no trip to the store
CH wine calm we also have next issue
back guys this this is one of my
favorite new ones two men next issue was
like Netflix for magazines only better
with access to all the latest issues all
right it's the new newsstand and like
Jay Larson tell you no one goes to a
newsstand anymore you know what a
newsstand is Blockbuster Video lately no
no because they're all gone that's right
and these magazines get delivered
directly to your phone or tablet alright
so here's the deal go to next issue calm
slash crab feast for is there you don't
even have to order there they are there
for a free trial all right it's a free
trial 30-day free trial sign up today
for a free 30-day trial no commitments
cancel anytime
alright all your favorite magazines
anytime anywhere eliminate the clutter
on your nightstand or in your Crab Shack
we're sitting here Larsen's got like a
stack it's stupid look at this golf
magazine ESPN Magazine Men's Journal
Travel and Leisure Sunset magazine all
of these you can get a next issue and
all of this yeah but you're getting all
of them one and it makes me feel like an
idiot because I like to respect I hate
having to recycle that she binge read
all your favorite magazines in one place
over 150 magazines like J just said ESPN
si men's health available for iPads
iPhones Android tablets and smartphones
if I read magazines this is what you
should have festive and if you travel
again don't buy all those expensive ass
magazines to the airport it's ridiculous
all right here's the deal go to next
issue calm slash crab feast and sign up
today for your free trial it's a fifteen
dollar savings and plans start as low as
$9.99 and one account can be shared with
up to five people five people so you're
paying like two dollars alright and you
get a you get a free month free it's a
great deal free month free you get a
free month free only available if you go
to next issue calm slash crab feast sign
up today you know what else is available
today this episode of the crab feast for
for free we're excited to have him back
fantastic comedians fantastic deviated
first episode it wasn't long enough
that's why they're back again we love
them to death to the nicest guys in
comedy please welcome back to the crab
feast the Sklar brothers Randy Jason
clap can you feel it
yeah can you feel it can you feel it yes
I can feel yeah
baseball's underway oh it's so good I
mean I hate goes down and I'm like
that's it it's over right the same looks
over I know that's us do you think they
should remove the D H from baseball or
should go and chop down some more trees
in a goddamn Carhartt commercial all
right and stop talking about the DEA to
Facebook
I think they should remove the DS and
put it in football that's what I love
because you guys are American League but
listen this is what I like the different
I love the National League for not
having it now look I love watching her
like I love and Ashley it's cute Ashley
it's cute
having to deal with the things and the
small ball it's cute never have I ever
told you my plan for what I would do
with baseball if I was a commissioner no
team James and put them all in Mexico
let Petros into the Hall of Fame but
this what I would do I would build like
a 30,000 seat stadium in Cooperstown and
every week that in a league game that
takes place is played in neutral site
and it's all old school there
everything's done old school people are
all supposed to do is drive it's for the
people in Cooperstown that's true they
have a home team now okay that would be
great I would do that we went up to
Cooperstown Brad do you believe that do
you believe
Randy's enthusiasm there I do he does I
do he buys it I'll buy it my enthusiasm
boom let's do it that's a buy real quick
yeah or we get very deep into this won't
you let everyone know we're anything you
want about the Sklar brothers right now
where they can find you on social media
where they can see alive well you can
see how we're doing this fun thing on
this for Eagle Regal Cinemas go ahead
Jeff you know you
you started it so get Regal Cinemas it's
called the trailer for people who are
fans of cheap seats of our old show
cheap seat race Atkins the fan please
welcome recording artist Tracey sepka so
no we we're doing this thing and it's
like cheap seats but for movie trailers
we basically break a new movie chosen
done a bunch of them I would say to all
of your fans who are who have been so
good to us go watch it type in reat
Sklar regal trailer you can see all the
ones we did we've done than YouTube on
YouTube we've done like mission
impossible when it came out
age of Ultron we did Tomorrowland there
so fun they're so funny we just next I
think this week it'll come out I think
it the Mad Max which holy [ __ ] man the
Mad Max that's a two and a half minute
masterpiece that great trailer trailer I
know it looks amazing right
I can't wait and when I first saw it I
was like oh wow they remastered the
original and I was like holy [ __ ] this
is a new one and then it made me realize
how good the original yes I gotta go
back original watch the original and
it's a trailer the trailer for that good
luck Blitzer little Wolf Blitzer [ __ ]
with it this is how good that trailer
was it made me go back and watch the
Tupac California oh yeah the whole video
was done to that in the Tupac video
there was a dirty headed Charlize Theron
as well and I believe two pockets in
this remake then in this new Mad Max and
as a hologram oddly at least two new
socks the wolf care was in both wolf
never age Allah never age he's stunted
he stays that was eaten by a werewolf at
a certain age and then just stayed it
made Mel Gibson yeah Mad Max made Mel
Gibson and it was for low-budge wasn't
it 1979 Australia was like the
highest-grossing film that's ever come
out of Australia I believe next to to
Wong foo thanks for everything Julie
Newmar
wasn't in Strictly Ballroom is that am I
wrong to say that I guess I couldn't
back you I I do allow you to go back and
watch what women want it is I'm trying
to think of what people were saying
where they were like just throw them in
there put him in a pair of pantyhose and
let him near women yeah you can hear
women can hear their inner thoughts I
think we'd be a lot different than that
that was the plot we used to do a bed
where it because he was so anti-semitic
we're like he goes back it's like a
Schindler's List type thing where he
gets zapped in a concentration camp and
he can hear the inner thoughts of the
people with Jews at the console it's
called sugar tits milk there's a trailer
Awards yeah we said we watched so many
trailers now you know what's good and
you know what isn't like there are some
trails we were just so freakin confusing
but then there are those that are just
they nail it they nail it and you're
like I want to see that like the new
poltergeist I'm like they nailed it
they'll only they trick you sometimes
with the trailer man they do their job
right sick bay you got to do it that's
that's ridiculous but Ernest terrible
Erna Erna tell Canada tell Erna to tell
Shack the storm what was it ghazan you
the cops of Ferguson
erna G Erna that's terrible
tell Shaq to stop promoting stuff on
here that's terrible or a nicer house
leave on a Buick early to tell shakes
over those terrible let's go behind my
ashton turner those terrible manners to
Bernie was at the early yesterday was at
the SPR the UH at the ESPYs with the
sports Emmys and he gave his for to me
to Stuart Scott starter that is why he
is that shows great we're saying like
Erna don't be giving that away I don't
care who is going to give a second one
to me or most concerning tell Shaq
that's terrible
Kareem abdul-jabbar is a six foot one
inch woman and I swear to God
white woman no white woman lost her
morning hey speaking of which what do
you who do you like for the playoff I
loved it ever since it's because Memphis
won yes yeah I don't know when this is
gonna drop but like Memphis finally came
out only with a face mask and a new life
it's really exciting I mean like I say
beat them I'm like anything's possible
anything is fun and the fact that the
Clippers who you know he's I think
they're going past the Spurs man now
they ruin life support I mean do you
root for McHale because he's coaching
now if you don't if the chief was
coaching I'd be like all day for the
cheese did you not like McHale I always
like okay got the best trivia questions
coaching he's always been kind of like a
you know like all right I like that
they're winning but I hate Dwight I just
gave some [ __ ] away here but I got the
best trivia question that someone asked
me since 1980 up till 2002 there were
five white players in the NBA who scored
25 points or more
can you knit average for the season
average for the season can you name well
L got to put in one game yeah I'll be of
course not McHale because I think McHale
wasn't well average 25 I know that's
after I know that sit around and
guessing on a thing is but hopefully
there are people that left speaker
shrimp is too early Steve Kerr not Wow
never did
now he was actually they were safe I've
never seen a Steve Nash that's too late
too late uh jeez who's that other white
guy that Sigma know Sigma no no who's a
Stockton stock Oh
Stockton never had 25 money had a lot of
assistant never 25 this is such a good
one come on you know you don't have to
of the city got 200 grand hill all right
we're now we're gonna get this I want to
know now do you want to know now what
Kailen bird mcallen bird surprising that
a Boston guy would get those two john
havelcheck
no not as Jason Williams white chocolate
yeah that's too late no no never this
first you remember someone come on think
about it Tom Chambers last 3rd Tom
Chambers is 3 who's always liked the
shot of like Tom Chambers dunking over
someone where his junk is in some dudes
face politician John stop Bill Bradley
that's too too early too early 1980 and
and that come on whoa listen right now
being like lam beer not Lamphere but
that's a good thought you just going
through all the way through Sean
grabbing I can come on Bradley Sean
Bradley I think he converted for people
to Mormonism many score points and I
don't even know I waved I waved the
white flag Chris Mullin John's baby Kiki
and Kiki management ever go to a Ralph's
will be on the program farting in my
mouth eight tiny Archibald will be
performing a reach-around on duck
there's one more and I completely forgot
to do this but there's one more and he
is a mustachioed man okay I'll get Oh
Kelly Tripucka no really tribute that
really Kelly Tripucka so wait that great
isn't that great it's such a great
question
it's literally like in the face of
LeSean McCoy making all those like Chip
Kelly's racist comments in the face of
all that it's like here's the futility
swipe you who's your team who do you
think is gonna win the NBA Finals I mean
that's what I was watching Golden State
last night because I think they're so
deep but Memphis dude Memphis is deep do
you how many guys they got that can just
come do you think Jeff Green is there
six men
dude the Bulls are deep like you look at
the Bulls bench is incredible
they're faster they're better Aaron
Brooks is insane look man I could see
the Bulls winning at all I mean I now
you ran us in the finals now you realize
that Atlanta is not for real I knew they
were phenomenal we were saying that
during the yeah no way I'm dark horsing
the Wizards oh I like the weather
dangerous they're just changes but
Bradley Beal is hurt so it's like you
know I wall no no walls her too but
Bradley Beals really hurt he's like he's
easy I should go back and look into
bullets I think they should go back to
being the bullets you know and I think
you could decided by just throwing a
rubber in front of their watch new
rubber bullets I would go - come on core
the Washington the Baltimore
come on man now welcome to our land
she's like Baltimore became you now know
what we experienced or was yeah I know
man it was such a bummer it was a parity
no you can't you can't that's unreal no
it was terrible and you know we're being
funny right now it's real it's allowed
to get real happy no it I want to ask
you so I'm going back to mass in June
and I you know we shot best bars at
Fenway right so I hit up my producer I'm
like hey can you see if we can get me to
throw out the first pitch over there
let's talk to a guy yeah the guys like
yeah
I got in touch with them he's like well
what are you guys filming I'm like no I
just thought you know I just I just try
to like I go I got some Z celebrity
status you know anything like if that so
yeah yeah exactly maybe 52 letters down
down and Russian now I want to see if I
could throw out the first pitch he's
like that's usually a themed thing and
I'm like themed thing yeah
theme is someone who's famous I know
theme dammit you'd be great people I
told her all no reason 81 crawl just
throw it through and out Dodger Saturday
night the fight night oh but he's he's
not an L a guy that no so that's famous
yeah but I feel like doing it in your
hometown you can definitely drop off
there are so many Boston people like
then they probably have Ben Affleck just
well James just muttering to himself as
he walks down the line I did not kill my
wife
yeah did my hint sisters did not own
slaves if you see when Will Ferrell
throw out the first pitch hide away oh
yeah as Louie Tiant yeah
if so everything he does and everything
he did is just perfect I think I would
like to get an old school car ride
remember needs to do got a chance to
throw it out in st. Louis on Jose
Oquendo bobblehead night this past year
and hold on a second Jose Oquendo am I
am I not correct in saying he played
every position in one game not one game
that's one season people people have now
distilled everything he's done that one
in it yeah he did in one in one batter
no no no he did to get one out of the
field he just ran around with one game
he's you know you know I mean I I know
is good friend who might be able to
answer Tommy her look at that perm guys
I can't believe you still wearing
activator so we went out to throw out
the first pitch and we now how did you
get how did you get this we had a TV
show I know but do you do they come to
you do you say hey we're gonna be home
this time we'd like to do this so no no
so I don't mean that deep we had the
Cleveland Indians asked us to throw out
the first pitch that's cool two years
ago and because there were someone in
there so in their social media or
someone was a huge fan of ours and
they're like are you guys can we see
that you're gonna be in club in Omaha
OMA in Omaha that kind of heading out
this way would you guys want to come out
and and we're like okay so we had our
booking agent get us in at Columbus and
then in Cleveland for a night where I do
the hilarities which is a phenomenal
club and Columbus the funny bone there
was fantastic amazing I made in a mall
you're like this has all the drippings
of being terrible and then it was
incredible just unbelievable the fans
were great so we go out there and we we
threw out the first pitch which was
great and in the Cleveland in Cleveland
and when we threw it out in Cleveland
who was catching you
I forgot their cat they're back to catch
it was it a backup the backup catcher
so at the same time or you know go
through it and were like here catch the
both of these I thought you each had
your own country through first that I
through second and I went submarine
style oh yeah yeah he's gonna find on
YouTube rubber are you kidding yeah oh
yeah and so you gotta warm up for that
they people think that they lowered the
mound for Bob Gibson they lowered it for
us so so so I did the move where you
know I went from the stretch faked like
I was gonna throw to third and then look
back to first I was like I'm gonna do it
just a pickoff move just to be silly
before my throw and some dude in the in
the box right next to the press box or
the box where we ended up be he's like
throw the ball he gets really mad and
he's pissed what's on the video of us
throwing this I took from this box so I
come back up and they're like and I come
to the box they're like that guy was
really mad he was like a 68 year old guy
I'm like hey bro I like I'm now I'm
gonna confront him I'm like it's
Cleveland it's September your team is
way out of it it's before the game like
what are you waiting for you so he took
a half an hour I was like I did a bit
for 30 seconds I'm like where do you
have to be [ __ ] you're like at the
game like you're 30 minutes early to see
us throw this pitch like once you have
another round of rings or onion round a
ring around a Rosie and I said to the
guy I can't there's nothing I can say to
you two - there's nothing mean I can say
to you that that's worse than what your
team has done to you this year exactly
so I'm gonna leave it at that but that
was that was that moment then do we
found out through I guess we said we
always want to throw out the first pitch
at the Cardinals game and then they were
like Jose Oquendo they're having Jose
Oquendo bobblehead night which you know
we did a special try and get Jose
Oquendo into the Hall of Fame whoa the
the end result was that we got a
homemade plaque this was on espn2 we had
a homemade plaque put on the hung on the
utility closet yes
I really do believe that the utility man
should be honored in baseball like just
like the pinch hitter like who is the
pinch hitter like Lennie Webster Russy
stop it's because like the sixth man
it's part of the game it's part of the
game like there should be a wing of like
odds and ends it's just day man the any
guy who's got three different gloves in
his bag because he might have to play
short he might have to play now we got a
claw and we were on the hill talking to
Tony LaRussa right before he fell asleep
at a traffic light field and we're
talking to Tony LaRussa and he goes and
we're doing this for the special and he
goes now I know you're not gonna use
this and the second he said no Gators
were like keep left it all in he's like
you don't understand if you have a guy
who can play eight or nine positions
that means you can carry an extra
pitcher I can carry a left-handed
specialist just to face left-handed guy
I can carry an extra guy later makes it
possible for you to do all these other
thing cuz I'm not carrying an extra
outfield because this guy can go out
there and play if I need him for a few
minutes amazing and he's a switch-hitter
so like he can face all pitching so it
was like he's like he is more valuable
than I think you are giving him credit
for we're like we're trying to get him
in the Hall of Fame yeah yeah
Cooperstown to try and lobby people and
it was really it was it was so much fun
so many hits did he have career 9:50
maybe 1200 1500 he also has more
postseason home runs than Ted Williams
that's right all right first of all slow
down right now yeah look I'm staring
right at me that's a big deal how many
how many gave you a frozen stare more
frozen than 10 how about this or so
maybe Ted Williams can give him one of
his Hall of Fame inductees since he's
into that Kendall
maybe he can give him one of his kids
who's incredibly depressed did you read
that article
one of the hall-of-fame tell Williams
then what he's into off a frozen torso -
mm-hmm cryogenic I know that's only
because he's told me this one for the
he's in the Major League Baseball Hall
of Fame College Baseball Hall of Fame no
no the argument for an army Hall of Fame
Ultimate Frisbee fly-fishing holiday
yeah I knew that you knew that because
you knew he did everything like to life
it has a Hall of Fame dude yeah you
river range on man does that there a
river no so we bought so we're always
tied to Jose Oquendo through this thing
and they were having Jose Oquendo
bobblehead night they said let's come
back so for a month for a month ranch
are throwing with our buddy gar well
yeah he's the best
you guys got to have moss so we're
throwing with him thrown with him and
and Randy's like I got to go submarine
style again because I really want to I
want to whip it as hard 121 hits I'm
like d6 panning him I'm like we got Hall
of Fame numbers all fans so I'm like we
got it I want to throw a curve I really
want to throw a curve and loop a curve
in there and so I'm working on the curve
working on the curve Randy's you're
going 12 six are you coming more from
like you know well six I'm not trying to
sidearm and I'm out it's not based on
his curved military time twelve to
fourteen twelve to eighteen hundred so I
throw it yeah I and I threw and so we
get out there to throw and like our kids
are with us and our moms down there on
the field and it's like a big deal and
they give us jerseys your kids there
well guys yelling at you oh yeah
and then like there's the this is what
kind of screwed us up I will say this
but I love that but like grope rely on
cameras on our like strapped around our
heads like we're minors so you can
actually so I'll become our perspective
footage together to put the footage
together of us throwing out the first
pitch from our perspective and which was
actually kind of cool and I and cuz
you've got me standing there watching
Jason throw it out from right behind him
at a place you would never have a camera
so it was actually really really cool I
heard it was like controversial though
because in the footage they just kept
here you're going I didn't kill my wife
I know I didn't realize the mic was off
yeah I think I killed them all I killed
them all delivery so Randy throws did
you throw first or do it I threw first
and I misjudged the distance just say
this and Oquendo is down catching so
like if so he if you don't like as spry
as he use if you don't literally put it
in his mitt I mean I could have gone
over and placed it in his mitt and he
would have dropped it no come on he but
he would have missed it
if you don't put my ball fine finds a
pen you know and so there was a 80 year
old photographer taking pictures of us
right there like taking pictures of us
throwing the ball and he was standing in
the left-hand left-hand batters so hard
in the way my joke is I threw it really
hit him I threw it so far left I brush
back Rachel Maddow
but I literally hit him in the shin we
need someone you need base runners knock
down Frank Robinson's Walker Covey in
the cane what out in the plate Oh little
to the left and then I and then I threw
a curveball it's like you can't be like
I'm just warming up and then Jacobs
perfect like a curve ball that broke
like a good like it would have frozen
people no would not a foo right down in
the strike zone it was really good it
was good it was fun and then but I felt
terrible after but I reminded me as we
were throwing here my when Randy made
the mistake reminded me of a story of
when this is now like 15 years ago when
I was single before I met her 1213 years
ago before I met my wife and I was just
on this like tear of dating women here
dude I just got married in Jason who had
been in a five-year relationship they
broke up so like you could not have
sklar's going in more divergent which I
didn't know like yeah kind of like gold
but it just happened that that way and I
had and I just you know I had my own
place and he was in with his wife and I
was just like.he around all the time
though just like a waste just like one
food no yeah but I was more like I'm
gonna try and be with every woman on
this earth I don't know why I just
needed to you know I was broken up with
I was cheated on so like I was feeling
low and I was feeling like I need to
just get out there so so I had this part
turn to eternity let's play too so I can
I just for one I'm gonna diverge from
that one thing there wasn't one this how
much we love baseball this night so we
were in teenage we were in Israel for
like six weeks right well I do not see
not birth right we went for those
semester this semester cause we were
with our buddy Ari so we were its
semester abroad junior year first
semester junior so ninety-two okay this
is 90 to go we went to Tel Aviv
University but we went to University of
Michigan so we left
so we go to Tel Aviv and we take a day
trip way up north way up north and it's
like the Lebanese border literally at
the Lebanese it's called the good fence
is what it was called the Lebanese
border and you wait for that parade some
bad people that's right you wait for at
the time everybody was kosher it was
fine but then and there was a get away
for the bus to take you back down but
because it's Saturday and it's the
Sabbath for the Jews the buses don't run
until a certain point in time when they
can then run and so we literally finish
what we were doing but had like two
hours to wait in this field next to the
bus stop and we found a cap from a
laundry detergent thing and me and Jason
this other kid for I would say an hour
and a half turn double plays with it we
do the ground or you had to go to second
get the tag and go back from we've got
every version do to every single person
all right so so back to the so um so I
have this party and I invite like three
women who I'm all and a bunch of people
and I remember was so embarrassed I had
a mojito station nice and I wrote mojito
and I spelled it wrong that's Mohi T so
so I but it was a really fun party and
like all the girls I really want to hook
with hook up with left and there was
another girl who was there who stayed
who I didn't you know she was kind of a
comedy like you know hanger-on or a
little bit and we started hooking up and
it's really like the worst hookup ever
it's just a lot of like padding on the
back shouldn't be the same as consoling
yeah congratulating some are consoling
right so sorry
sorry weird and it wasn't good and then
I drove her holiness and gentleman trace
adkins there's a point this I'm bringing
around okay so so so then like a couple
weeks and then I just never called her
back because I was like that couldn't
have been good for her there was that
wasn't fun for and yeah I won't see her
in the comedy scene yeah so I go to to
all comedians like softball game and and
we're just not Marshall right at
Marshall I believe it wasn't Marshall
yeah so I'm so we're throwing the ball
around before the game and I'm throwing
to this is 2001 so again this is a Space
Odyssey yeah
suppose 9/11 so we're all in a little
bit of a sponsorship but no so I'm
throwing the ball to this girl who's a
dynamite lesbian could good glove
flashing the leather and I'm throwing it
to her she's standing right at first
base I'm at second base and we're all
just warming up and throwing and I see
coming down the right who do I see
coming down the right-field line but
this girl the heavy patter and and this
other it's so bad and I'm throwing with
this and this is before like Twitter or
you're tweeting it outers right no no
for Foursquare where you knew she was
gonna be so I'm throwing I'm throwing
I'm throwing and they walk into that I
got I kind of lose tracking them and I'm
just throwing to this girl and then I
release and I know the second I release
no it's hi all right better get up she's
got like acid rudeness
Ilgauskas vertical it goes down yeah
like there was a point when Zoo judicial
Gauss's would go for a jumper
you couldn't slide a piece of loose-leaf
paper underneath his feet
so I duck she ducks she got lower and
went over and all I hear is like a smack
of ball against skin and I say to myself
oh dear God
I do and a crowd of people rush around
oh like and I run in and I'm like last
to run in and and she's what tears
crying crying crying all these people
around her son so I'm like I'm like the
console setting her back again as she
consults weirdly she looks up with
everybody around everyone around sees me
and through tears says why didn't you
call me back now you just hit me now you
just hit me and now and that story
reminded uh you and we were talking
about when we were playing baseball in
our front yard cuz we used to throw the
ball in the front yard forever
yeah and any time someone did a bad
throw we just wouldn't blame the [ __ ]
out of each other be like great that's
good I just get on each other like it
was you who made the girl like you know
how you can get on yourself yeah in a
way that no one else is allowed to get
on you well that is like the secret of
our you know sports relationship me and
J is that we can get on each other the
way you would get on yourself so like if
we're playing pick-up basketball or
whatever and like he screws up like I'll
just take it and just whip it at him
like I'd rather be on the opposing team
than on his team we don't want to be on
the same team because now is that if you
screw up then that's it I'm a twin so my
whole life because you have parents that
don't want to take two kids to different
places you play with each other the
inside play tennis go up to the junior
high school bankin [ __ ] you ain't you
I can't wait cannot wait so so we're in
the front yard and we throw and I throw
it past Randy and it again basically the
same motion same throw goes over his
head bounces up and hits the front
headlight of the car parked in our
neighbors but yeah it literally puts a
baseball-sized hole in this head like
Randy and so we the ball bounces back we
grab it and oh we should mention that
our neighbors we're like we're like I
think they're still our neighbors like
in mid 70s late 70s Germans like
straight up she was I don't know who's
she she I think she's our Lester I don't
know
germán by for this your kind of dude was
like so nice that you're like what the
don't be so nice doctors that yeah it's
one of those thing either but I do I I
have to admit though there's a time now
where I'm reading this I'm reading I'm
we're digressing so many times when I'm
reading a story to my one and a half
year old daughter I know we your dot
your sons one in like he's four months
like 14 almost 15 months so I will read
him read her this story Ghazi and Gertie
which is a great book but the way I read
it for some reason I think this is the
funniest thing in the world I try to
read it like I'm ray Fiennes in
Schindler's List so funny to me Gussie
this is getti I love it so I'm imagining
like I'm sharpening a knife what are you
do she just loves it sharpening a knife
hi this is vet I do something play and
say hey it's I read in his little book
when he's in the bath about this rainbow
fish and all these other fish one is
rainbow scales it's a little rubber one
for the tub but then like goes hey can I
have on your scales and the and the
rainbow fish says never but every time I
do it he goes yes or no scales and I
know rainbow fish goes he waits for it
comedy it's so gay alright so that's my
little back into Germany so rainy I we
made with we break the headlight and we
run in our basement and we hide which is
kind of ready for it yeah Jews hiding in
a basement from a German that's the
metaphoric in many levels I know cops
show up no it's not a Mercedes it was
not ever seen cops show up and and
they're like yeah because because our
house is built on a hill you could the
basement window you could look out yes
faith there's a window facing what's
that so we're huddling in the basement
like shade draw it like Levellers down
and we're like peeking through to him
and looking at the cops writing up a
report about what happened here so
clearly the trajectory of what the
happen is what's there and we should
have come out and said something about
it but we just so afraid that I don't
know what we did and so and then like
two days later we went back to college
yeah we were 20
to them if I had the money to pay for
that that's what we were thinking about
as Jays throwing up but we are slated to
throw out the first pitch for the Tigers
game in Detroit September 25th which is
University of Michigan night I think so
I gotta really work on it I gotta decide
what I'm gonna do I cannot throw it left
again I just can't I gotta throw a
strike because when I threw it in
Cleveland I whipped it I mean I whipped
it about $75 I was [ __ ] tell you got a
do I mean you're plenty of time to prep
for come on the Nook bro he can throw it
throw a knuckler throw the know I might
throw not yeah that would catch her me
like I can get it to work one out of
every four pitches yeah I cannot throw
nonsense don't want to throw it in the
dirt like like that's it you'd rather be
hot it's the rule if you get to do it
you got a thrill just hit Alan Trammell
one he was up in the mood Whittaker just
went down no they're not booing me
they're just saying they just hit him in
the balls
Jay you're not gonna be able to throw uh
after rain take out Miguel Cabrera we
injured Magglio Dorn yes we played I
played in high school with a kid Shawn
Thompson he was like 64 super lanky and
he pitch and he had a crazy nook yeah
and we were legit our high school team
was like number one in the state 2015
the country like you're legit and Shawn
Thompson our coach would get so mad cuz
he'd have guys
Owen - and my boy tio double was the
catcher
he'd be like throw a knock he would and
it'd be like dancing everywhere pass
ball guy would get on first he came to
me one time before like we playing catch
before the game you know just getting
loose and light into your nuts now it
went over my glove cain't dipped back
down no lie knocked my hat off like hit
the brim and went over
I was like dude no more it was sick they
do they dance they stay down and up
that's down look at a guy that like
that's the knuckleball pitchers the
outer shape guy who looks like he's like
the backup third-base coach Charlie
grandpa does he die in six months why
are they letting him pitch Sox have a
knuckleball right now I don't know his
name but he's they got one guy like he's
in the pan I don't know where his I feel
I've always said that if ever there was
gonna be a woman to play in baseball if
she had a killer knuckleball she could
play well you know that chick that like
learn from Tim Wakefield what's her name
she's like a high skinned Wakefield
Kimmie Wakefield okay gonna believe
Timmy Wakefield threw a knuckleball
riding the left field they got a [ __ ]
strike uh I'll tell you a story I
haven't told this it's been a long time
as I told this but you'll appreciate
this this was this was years ago I don't
know maybe five nineteen years ago maybe
more I was a Sunday afternoon I was
single by myself I was leaving a
friend's place in Beverly Hills and I
see this little league game going on and
I pull over and I'm like you know what I
haven't watched good Little League not
five six year olds you know
competitively buzzing with an Amber
Alert so I pull off in a neighborhood I
smoke a little joint and I supposed to
in the bleachers and I go to the top of
the bleachers and I'm sitting on
third-base side and it's a competitive
game and the coach for the team on the
third-base side is a dick and he's just
like laid a bunt down that you know
screaming at these kids and he's the
peas he's bringing in a left-handed kid
to pitch to a left-handed batter and
make a boost
he's a parents are like come on man you
know and they're starting to politely
say hey you know yeah take it easy bro
when's Kim Wakefield getting this
she been warming up for finings get her
a brick to get the golf car bring Jimmy
get the Hat cab bring her in so this
guy's really he's overdoing it
completely overdoing it and now he's you
know he's ruining the fun for the kids
and there's bass there's here I say
harshing on your buzz oh definitely hard
to mother not cool and there's one guy
down in the front and I hear him say
come on coach
what are you doing and he just like mind
your business I'm coaching this team and
my god what a dick and the guy sort of
turns his head a little bit and I can
see you know the old-school man glasses
with the chain when he turns I could see
gold chain sort of dangle okay so I'm
sumus guys maybe 60s is in 60 yeah and
there's a man on first and second I'm
sorry a kid on first and second thank
you
and coach intentionally walks this next
kid to get to the kid double play and
then this guy again is like all right
that's enough man come on this is
ridiculous let these kids play and he's
like you shut your mouth you sit there
and you be quiet you don't tell me how
to do and I'm looking and there see the
guy oh my god that's Pete Rose no this
guy [ __ ] stands up he's like you
don't talk to me like that it's Pete
[ __ ] Road it's Pete Rose I gotta say
oh here comes Philly guy Philly guys
gonna give you his opinion heroes should
be a Hall of Fame his wife Shmi an asian
wife Hall of Fame who else should be
there's money chunks me an asian wife
whole thing because she's always talking
about her heirloom tomato garden I'm a
huge you definitely not be she should go
down walk her ass down to the Wawa I'm
15 locust and get us a water ice just so
you know that's all so you can if anyone
ever asked you to do Baltimore just do
that try on all your elves yeah I always
this is how you say Billy Dee Williams
in Baltimore oh wow what's that black
fellas name in Empire Strikes Back Oh
Billy Dee Weems
we will we do
while my huge belly dear I love baby we
know what Billy Dee Williams is he from
Cherry Hill how are we I'm a huge
Mohammed fan I hate the fact he's
shaking around I swallow Isaac ouch
hey he's a college kid I'm a huge you
know Ben Franklin Franklin had fly some
kites and just get some electricity out
here I pull your horse around the alley
yeah hold out horse around tie it up
there's one more thing I want to say to
the house representatives and everybody
here in conference Pete Rouse should
definitely be in the Hall of Fame his
wife Deanna a weapon I built a time
machine I went to the Future hello Pete
Rose were here right now I'd sign his
name on a Declaration of Independence I
don't care I don't care well right now
philia am I in my world at this time
Pete Rose is in my personal Hall of Fame
believe it's pets it's a it's I wouldn't
say you packed bleachers but there's
considerable people all know he was
there they definitely definitely yeah so
what happened was I got a hundo on this
game I want to make my best count all
right I was talking to Gary Sheridan I
gotta clean this stuff up clean it up
what about Halle knows I'm a huge
hallway notes fan daryl hall has a huge
philia have you seen I love there all
I'm gonna be live from Daryl's place
yeah so Joe Hall's got this you love it
he's got the smoothest voice ever and he
bring along there all he brings on
artists other artists to come on and a
house built powered huge Phil Collins
family what does like be brought on Cee
Lo's like Cisco see where you are CEO
you want me to get you
like you know he's got like this
smoothest voice ever but then he just
started talking he's like yeah I'm a
huge family see well you or do what
you're something you can do I can't go
for that okay we'll do that
yeah run down to roll farm get
cigarettes real quick get a cup of
scratch so for about the new I can't go
for that I can't get hey you I can't go
for the I can't go for losing the
scratch off I can't go for raising
heroes nothing I can't go Ruby Rose this
is Gerald hull I can't go for that put
it in the Hall of Fame daryl hall &
oates is the name of the band and it was
hauling out its daryl hall & oates is
the name of the band that's what it
should be nope not daryl hall no you
don't put his first name is Daryl Hall
and it was so Petros is having a
confrontation with this manager now and
I'm in my own but you know little league
men and I I can't get over it you know
I'm like holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] Pete
Rose Charlie and you're high you're like
this only half I didn't smoked I
wouldn't have been there if I didn't
smoke that was Manny Trillo I love Larry
Bowa so the coach tells Pete Rose to
shut up like he really disrespects him
completely what heroes are not he
completely dissed as human being okay
but Pete Rose heroes whose [ __ ]
telling you like you know dial it back
right these are [ __ ] kids if he said
dial it back so the inning changes and
what happens is it's Pete Rose I guess
he's married another time or something
has a young a 10 year old or 11 year old
he's pitching so he throws a ball one
gets fouled off back over behind the
bleachers
mm-hmm I saw my opportunity to slip off
I got that ball got him to sign it let
that [ __ ] my pocket sat there for the
rest of the game and I usually throw
that back yeah you only playing with one
who might be able to be in an office
right you never know so games over and I
walk up to Pete Rose and I'm wearing an
Orioles batting
Jerzy mesh blackboard or injury and
single lady repellent a visor that says
the Masters so I have him this is the
second time this is the first time has
happened to me twice
I have Pete Rose sign the ball no way
how much that cost you the pen dies gets
the pee out that's done I mean done done
he's like I'm sorry man I'm like so he
leaves with his kid and I sprint back to
the dugout and sprinting high is never
gone man that shit's over now that buzz
ended when I saw the ink dry like it was
all like gone so I run over and I'm like
there was four like wives we're talking
amongst each other I'm like - honey
ladies have a pen in your purse she's
like yeah ends up being his wife out on
those I run back over ammo out of breath
so he signed it and I have I had it for
a while and I ended up giving it to I
just passed on to my cousin who thought
I was he's like this is like a Ty Cobb
ball yeah yeah I get it better you know
he's really not signing a lot of stuff
so I don't want to ask you if you've
ever heard this I heard that he goes up
to the Cooperstown yeah and sets up shop
also so yes he does he was being defiant
I don't think he does it anymore
the only one I can believe we don't need
to get into it but the gold standard in
baseball for hits is 3,000 and what does
he have 1700 more than that yeah no
4,100 he's like 41 or 40 40 42 and
changed in 40 to 30 so under my and I
always felt like you know that's but I
always felt like if Jeter played three
more years and he could have he might
have gotten to fourth did if Ichiro it
started in America you're right he would
be at 4000 I don't know if you would
break the record would he'd be at four
right well let me say this you could
take Jeter and Jose Oquendo you still
don't get P right and that's why that's
on Jose Oquendo
another time i when rick can play for
the orioles nice to go see him in
anaheim all time and he would always go
early and sign autographs for like an
hour and a half before the game so I
knew this I have this special ball when
he broke the streak it was orange it was
you know how to a Don at 21 31 only used
whatever
rubbed on Gary thorns taint for I'm with
my girlfriend at the time and this girl
was one of those times where you outdo
yourself she's gorgeous and we're next
okay and I have a pen and this kid walks
away and leaves his pen with cow and
cows like you just when we used this pen
and I was like yeah that's fine see a
pen like [ __ ] oh he's blushing at her she
said you have pretty eyes to cal ripken
and he blushed and i was like damn and
he'd but he doesn't steal my god so he
signed CA and it dies and i'm like yeah
he's like just want me to sign another
you want me to go over and I was like no
hell no sign another side of the ball so
he signed another again clean uh-huh
so I've got it like that and that and
this groom yeah nice where's that ball
I haven't oh yeah what why well what is
the legend of she went this Kawhi
Leonard mystery where Costner's banged
his wife yeah I mean that's the story
I've heard what's the story I need to
hear from what I'll tell you what I have
what I've really really heard there's a
few things I've heard that have all come
out so that day cow goes to the game and
forgets one of his gloves supposedly
sends an equipment guy back to the house
to get the glove the equipment guy sees
some [ __ ] going down now that part is
supposed to be true the Kevin Costner
parts a little muddy there are strong
rumors that there was a pool guy and
there's also rumors that was Costner
just because he was in town and shooting
and he was at the games I don't know if
that's true or not I'm not Bangor in his
dances with
layna flute
I heard cut it was there but I heard
that rip getting cost I got in a fight
over the postman freaking I guess koklos
man oh yes our world the story then is
the equipment guy drives back says you
need to go home now and he's like what
he thought my zit you need to go home
now he goes home they having a physical
altercation countless wife pose no
nothing in costner or whoever that guy
is
Plus how supposedly beats his ass they
don't want to arrest him I don't know if
he was ever arrested but that night was
the Seattle that was the Seattle
Mariners and right field in Camden Yards
streak would have absolutely been broken
huh the hand I think happened in the
brawl with Seattle which was he broke
his hand get ready to go in the all-star
game they're like kind of things gonna
be able to play but anyway so that night
cows not back and the right-field lights
just go out the only time it's ever
happened in Camden Yards history yeah
never since never before and ever since
and that game was canceled next day cows
back at the state that's unreal all the
things that have to conspire in order
for you to break a record like that
that's I mean that was everyone was
behind that guy for the record all of
baseball everything I I couldn't get a
ticket but I went to the stadium that
night of the game and I went to a bar
right outside the stadium and went in a
great area I mean that whole thing yeah
that area on the other side is not that
side I was on Zinn a really nice area I
mean everywhere in ball the ballpark it
was the ancient Jim Abbott was on the
other team I remember that yeah I think
he was yeah he was because I remember I
watched the game in the game a big hand
getting the biggest hand of all and when
Michigan Blair he hit that home run I
remember correctly he had a home run the
night before when he tied it and then he
hit one the night he broke it the night
he broke it I mean that city was you
just poked your head out the window it
was
not a chill it was Island miles just
hearing none means why we get mine
believe host left st. Louis I get mad
because I'm like you could have had that
you could have done that really like
sailors went to the World Series now
twice you know one time since you left
and almost made it there another time
and you're playing for a team that
didn't make the playoffs but what more
did you need and so you know it's like
literally all about money and I'm like
well 260 million in la la is a lot less
than 200 million in st. Louis well it
just is less you could have been stay on
the Musial you could have been stand the
Musial I was I mean I'm lucky as a
sports fan whatever you think of Ray
Lewis Ray Lewis also beginning to end
and in Baltimore then killing it they
put they put him in on the last
formation when we were in against the
Colts in the playoffs and let him be in
the last play yeah in his home stadium
he gets to do a lap yeah and tell us I
mean how he got his tricep ripped from
the bone and then said I'm coming back
it was the first year they allowed that
designation where you could bring
someone back gave it to him and he told
the guys and said this is my last ride
and then they win then we won the
football I know that I mean and went out
on a fourth and goal stand against
whatever great career had there not been
that one tiny little scheme above a
person getting killed I mean I know why
we all love those guys like for us Manny
Ramirez you know I mean Pedro Martinez
guys have come up through the season to
get the Pedro book guys that knows
you've got a new book called Pedro oh
man I'm very excited to see that but I'm
with amazing stories about no no but I
just read about it that Manny Ramirez
gave everyone in the dugout viagra I
mean there's like a crime like he showed
up and like went on like big Papi's
underwear and I mean he would just like
put on other dudes clothes
he's just man it was just Manny being
not even just a clown but he was just
like crazy psycho I don't know it's like
the tracy morgan of baseball exactly
exactly I think we'll never forget that
what he did for the Dodgers when
remember when he came over there was
it was really that estrogen infused half
half of a season that was just amazing
amazing tits were so great is this more
sports than has ever been spoken about
on the crab now I mean who cares no
there's the least their sports stories
and not just our opinions of what
happened to share things my favorite
thing about sports talk radio the thing
that I hate the most central let's break
it down and there's like the Cubs you
know anyway I cannot stand when that's
the worst type of laziest rating laziest
radio ever we're like let's go NSC
I mean they just go down the teams I'm
like shut the [ __ ] actually have a take
that's why we love Rome so much it's
like he literally has a he prepares and
has to take for every the thing it's
either you disagree with it or agree
with it but at least he's got to take
yeah yeah I mean I can't believe that
you know I just with the draft and all
that stuff like I can't believe people
worship who who I'm saying is gonna be
drafted mmm-hmm there's no it's just
your guess it's a total guess it's a
total game maybe one and two or and yeah
we're Ram sense would you girly
they got girly who's great he's a mate
boy he's a little too girly for me Todd
girl ha that's it just brought joy those
amazing girly they say he might be
better than that
my name bro come on in come on hands who
are we talking to you last night who
said they thought Jay Larson was mad at
him
baron von did he say like I just had
that conversation with Baron von that he
thought that you were ready I was like
he's doing a bit now I was mad
you were mad because he was late for
five minutes or something or you know he
just pronounced the crab feast he called
the crab fest now everybody has that man
I mean well now that we're talking about
he's out there talking about basically
we were gonna have baron on the on the
podcast yeah and I love him and I texted
yeah me too I've always I used to share
an office with him I'm gonna tell you
right now so I texted him day-out office
may man just want to make sure we're
we're good to go for tonight he's like
oh I booked a show I'm doing doing
stand-up tonight I'm like oh well we
booked the podcast he's like yeah I know
I just told these people I would do the
stand-up show and it was like 5:30 we're
recording at 8:00 and I'm like well
what's what's it gonna be like you know
your man make your decision he goes well
I I just gave my word I would do the
show and I'm like yeah you told us to do
the show too and he's like yeah I don't
know and I'm like all right man well I'm
just gonna cancel it then cuz you know
we got to figure it out and he's like oh
he goes well now I'm thinking maybe he'd
be better to do your podcast than to do
the show and I wrote back I'll you think
it'd be better to do a podcast for
thousands of people than a coffee shop
show that we wrote back to him yeah ooh
boy and and I was just like okay it's
not late look at you cancel stand-up
show there's eight people on the
stand-up show that's right someone can
everyone can stretch two minutes you
cancel a podcast that comes out once a
week this is then you kind of put people
since why I'm still married so my wife
last night we have a set last night at
meltdown at 9:30 we're supposed to go on
meanwhile was late the way it was all
set up but she was gonna take a sewing
class in Atwater Village
that she told me end of the day I had
not told her that I was gonna go to a
spot at night because I figured she'd be
asleep and I'll just leave and I'll just
go to think then she tells Springs on me
it's from 6:30 to 9:30 and I was just
like I have a spot at 9:30 and the show
is supposedly starting like at 8:30 and
we have to be on that and there's only
three people on it and we have to do our
thing like you we have to cancel this
thing and she was like I booked a
stand-up show with barren pond and I was
like No
she back down and she was like I'll find
another time to take it and that's why
that's why I'm not married a baron von I
mean let me say this for the ride
Alabama I love Baron and I think he's my
to suit the guys in town amazing but I'm
I'm too old to make excuses for people
for being unaware you know what I mean
like if you don't understand I get that
that something that happens 52 times a
years versus you know I mean we only do
52 so that's my thing if guys cancel on
us
last-minute I'm like all right you're
being unprofessional and you're not like
Dolph Lundgren did with us [ __ ] Dolph
Lundgren was supposed to be on our
podcast and just backs out last minute
and we said this on our podcast and I'll
say it on your podcast too
you want a piece of us Dolph let's go
I'll come two on one will set up the
punching machine we'll see how hard
you're still it's two on one you know my
buddy was the eight rounds of steroids
we're all let's go that's right you saw
the movie yeah my buddy's an editor of
what was that movie he does with Van
Damme they've done only three of them
The Expendables no he wasn't in the last
external switch means he's basically
what does that mean when you're like we
don't need you for the expenditure
everybody yeah that's our Universal
Soldier okay so my buddy was editing it
and we and I used to go to his office
all the time in New York what does that
mean Universal Soldier but that movie
but by the very nature of being a
soldier you have to pick a side if your
universe are more than one universe he
fight a man he fights for universal
studios Visor universal healthcare so
Universal using it and he goes hey you
want to see some of the dailies from
Universal Soldier - I want to see all
the daily let me just show you this dam
has longeron up against the wall and
then they go cut and so they cut and
Lungren let's down and Van Damme goes
boom and pops him in the face with an
elbow no no we released that anything
what happened why did you cuz they hate
each other those two guys hate each
other they hate each other that's what I
heard but how is Van Damme allowed to
hit him
with an elbow after the bell that to me
feel yeah he lost a point lost a point
and he's supposedly Lungren supposedly
has like a 200 IQ yeah
someone said he's got a 200 IQ IQ come
on who says that I think it was Brigitte
Nielsen who said and she said it to
flavor play I can't so then it made its
way there probably styling Brigitte
Nielsen and they're like note we got to
make her look more Lundgren and make it
look like a dude look more angry
have you ever seen the I think it's a
Volvo commercial van Damme doing a split
yeah two tractors recently he released
that and the trucks were going backwards
I think I don't think they were going
forwards I don't know yeah point whose
ride what was the point is that what the
point was yeah if you ever find yourself
doing the splits on top of a truck yeah
if you ever the enemy or window to
window whenever he was that commercial
was sick yeah I was amazing it was
amazing and like somewhere like Steven
Seagal was like impressed eating his
third cronut and he's like when we go
back to Russia
it would be be whispering well I know we
got to get you guys out of here it's
it's about that time
yeah yeah all right guys well thank you
for doing this a lot of fun as always
fine one more time please plug promote
anything you like please if all of you
go and watch these trailer things that
we're doing it's Regal Cinemas if you
just type in Sklar regal trailer on
youtube all of them will come up watch
them like them all that stuff listen to
our podcast we just had Gilbert Godfrey
on he was amazing
Barbra Country Club Road Country it's
free on iTunes all right here wolf or a
canary pocket and then the let and then
god oh then in mid right mid mid June
third weekend in June were in San Diego
at the at the American comedy company
doing shows down there which were really
excited about and and of end of August
were actually gonna be in Wisconsin at
comedy club on state which is a great
comedy club fest love it as always Jay
Larson comic con jealous and common
across social media Ryan Sickler comm
Ryan Sickler on
Instagram Facebook will talk to y'all
next to the heroes